CYNTHIA THOMAS: Hi.
This is Cynthia
Thomas, and I'm back
to give you the latest on
Google Cloud Edge and security
networking launches that
have recently gone GA.
Stick around.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Cloud Armor-- what is it?
It's Google Cloud's DDoS defense
service and web application
firewall that works to protect
your applications and websites.
Cloud Armor protects
your applications
against DDoS attacks using
the same technology that's
used to protect
Google's own services.
Additionally, a host of security
capabilities are available.
But in this video, we'll focus
on the latest and greatest
that are now GA.
Cloud Armor policies
have now been
extended to help you mitigate
the top 10 OWASP web app
vulnerabilities in an
easy-to-configure fashion.
The new preconfigured WAF rules
include scanner detection,
protocol attack, PHP injection,
and session fixation.
The available
preconfigured rules
are based on OWASP
ModSecurity core rules set.
The rules allow Cloud
Armor to evaluate
dozens of distinct
traffic signatures
by referring to
conveniently named rules,
instead of requiring you to
define each signature manually.
They can be tuned to different
sensitivity levels, as well.
Cloud Armor also
launched the capabilities
to parse JSONs,
filter based on ASN,
and enable verbose logging.
Incoming requests with
JSON as the content type
often report a
high rate of noise
and false positive hits from
preconfigured WAF rules.
With this release, you
can now enable Cloud Armor
to parse the JSON formatted
content of HTTP requests
on a per-policy basis.
Once enabled, you
can significantly
reduce the noise and false
positive alerts for workloads
with requests containing JSON.
Another available rule attribute
is filtering based on an ASN.
Cloud Armor lets you allow or
deny incoming requests serviced
from a specific network operator
defined by their autonomous
system number.
Finally, you can get
more logging information
of incoming requests.
By default, event logs
contain the security rule
that was triggered.
With verbose
logging, Cloud Armor
can generate additional
details in the request
logs to include a snippet of
the offending content that
triggered the rule.
Next, let's talk about
additions to VPC Service
Controls, your Google Cloud
service perimeter defense tool.
VPC Service Controls works
to prevent data exfiltration
and is a hard requirement for
several financial services
customers.
It defines a service
perimeter that
lets you protect your
organization's information
by controlling
access to resources
and manage services data.
Now VPC Service
Controls has expanded
the services you can include
in the service perimeter.
It now includes the
Cloud Filestore API.
Filestore is a Google-managed,
network-attached storage
solution.
It works with VMs and
Google Kubernetes Engine.
And with VPC Service
Controls, you
can now control and protect the
Data Exchange with Filestore.
Finally, let's talk about
VPC Service Controls
Troubleshooter.
This is a new tool that enables
admins to better understand
a denial caused by
VPC Service Controls.
Defining your
security perimeter can
be tricky while
debugging denial errors.
You can now easily
investigate issues
related to VPC Service Controls
using the Cloud Console.
Use the VPC Service
Controls Troubleshooter
via the Logs Explorer or from
the VPC Service Controls page.
Once you enter a unique
ID for the logged error,
you'll be provided with
one of the violation
reasons for further
insights into the denial.
Very handy for
confirming and defining
your service perimeters.
All right.
Now you're up-to-date on the
latest networking and Edge
security launches.
Check out the docs linked
below and let us know
what you think in the comments.
Join us next time for
"What's New In Networking."